[Music]
the david pakman show
at davidpakman.com
welcome to the bonus show california
legislators have approved
a more than seven billion dollar covid
relief package including six hundred
dollar
stimulus checks and that money could
arrive
as soon as a month after filing tax
returns this is a
california-based coveted relief bill
totally separate
from the federal coveted relief bill
that's currently being considered
evaluated and discussed by joe biden
democrats and republicans
governor gavin newsom and legislative
leaders put it together last week
it includes more than two billion
dollars in grants and fee waivers for
small businesses
businesses will soon be able to apply
for the grants and there will be an
approval process expected to take 45
days
there will be an additional 2 billion in
tax breaks for businesses
which would bring the package all the
way up to almost 10 billion dollars
and then the stimulus assistance for
people earning under 30
000 a year will come four to five weeks
after they file
their 2020 tax returns um this
is very interesting pat for a few
different reasons
one that it's not been much discussed
that throughout this pandemic states can
also do their own stimulus now
a lot of states can't really afford it
and are sort of reliant on the federal
government anyway if they want to
do something like this which is i think
part of the reason why many states
haven't gone forward
california's budget problems are widely
known and yet
they are pushing forward with this and i
think that it's going to be
a very welcome relief to many
californians
yeah i think it's a good decision of
course the federal government can print
as much money as it wants whereas state
governments can't do that
and that's why you sometimes run into
these problems and that's why it's often
seen as
the federal government's responsibility
to provide stimulus but states can do it
too
and they actually had this extra money
because they were expecting to have less
revenue come into the state last year
right they thought that unemployment
would be higher and they also didn't
expect the stock market to do as well as
it did last year and so that means that
they got a lot of extra money off of
capital gains taxes from some of the
richest people who live in california
and this is a great way to i think
redistribute wealth i mean the people
who qualify for these stimulus checks by
and large are making under 30 grand a
year
and you know that money is coming from
people who probably made a fortune off
of wall street over the past year so
i like to see it and it seems like a
good move to me what do you think
is going on right now with the federal
stimulus bill from the standpoint of
is joe biden specifically waiting for
something and if so what is he waiting
for i think at this point he's waited
long enough to see
if republicans are willing to get to get
on board and help i just don't
understand at this point what he's
waiting for
from what i saw a few days ago it's just
going through procedural hurdles right
now because the bill passed the house
has to go to the senate and then the
senate parliamentarian has to take a
look at it and see
is this the type of thing that we can
even pass through budget reconciliation
or does it have to be its own standalone
bill
they have to work out the provisions
like the 15 minimum wage
of course the house and the senate have
to pass the exact same version of the
bill
so it's just one of those things where
washington takes time to to pass things
but i think that we can expect to see
that passed in the next
couple of weeks and then signed into law
thereafter i think biden's mistake with
all this was to say that he would be
able to get it done in his first week or
so
right they probably knew at that time
that it wasn't true uh but hopefully it
comes sooner than later
let's let's hope so because even with
the timeline you're suggesting which is
passage in a couple of weeks getting
signed into law we're
likely looking at april or even may for
people getting checks i mean that's
that's just how long this is this has
been taking when we looked at the past
packages
and that is i mean listen i hope things
are dramatically better at that point in
time
but for a lot of people that's just not
an acceptable amount of time to wait
right so then you'd be getting a
stimulus payment in may of 2020
a stimulus payment in april of 2021 and
just like the 600
in between those two clearly that's not
enough
and yes the government has been dragging
its feet on this uh but
i would hope that this is like the last
one we have to
negotiate and pass and soon enough we'll
be able to get back on our feet as a
country and uh
hopefully be able to move beyond
stimulus but it could take some time one
of the things that is increasingly also
a problem for joe biden is the
confirmation
of nira tandon that's joe biden's
selection to run the office of
management and budget also known as omb
now from day one i have said that this
is joe biden's worst
nomination nira tandon is from the
center for american progress wing of the
democratic party
really a sort of democratic
establishment
insider i don't care about her mean
tweets about bernie sanders that's
become an
issue joe manchin who is one of 50
democratic senators
has said that he will not be supporting
her because some of the things that she
has previously said
but yet joe manchin voted to approve
brett kavanaugh despite the things that
brett kavanaugh previously did and said
so the reasoning that joe manchin is
giving i find to be uh
very unmotivating and unconvincing but
i don't think people like nira tandon
should have any
role to play in an administration that i
want to have
as far removed from these sort of
establishment democratic institutions as
possible
and as competent as you can say nira
tandon is
i thought that she was exactly what we
don't need in a biden administration
her nomination really may now be in
trouble because without
joe manchin not only do democrats need
every remaining democrat all 49 they
also now need one republican and so far
we've learned that
mitt romney is not going to support the
nomination of nira tandon
susan collins is not going to support
the confirmation
of nira tandon this is increasingly an
uphill battle pat even though for now
joe biden has continued to say i think
we're going to find the votes
they may not actually find the votes for
nearest handed which i think would be a
good thing
i wonder if bernie sanders will vote to
confirm her too because a lot of those
tweets went after bernie sanders
specifically
right my thought is bernie tends to be a
team player so because joe biden wants
near tandon as
his officer of management and budget he
may just decide to go along with it and
vote for her
but we'll have to see what happens here
we've talked a lot about how joe manchin
is going to be a thorn in our side over
these next two years we've been saying
that ever since we won those two seats
in georgia yeah if this is the issue
that he wants to
blow off steam on if this is the one
that he wants to pick go for it let it
out of your system now joe manchin so
then we can pass
things like covert relief and some of
the other things we want to pass in
these next two years get it all done
with niro tandon here i tweeted the
other day
this is the most interesting thing joe
manchin has ever done as far as i'm
concerned although he's doing it for
reasons that i find to be very weak now
one other note on this
you can start to see that
the perspective on this within the white
house is shifting a little bit
because in yesterday's press briefing
when
uh joe biden's white house press
secretary jensachi was asked about
nira tandon she said joe biden wouldn't
have picked her
if he didn't think she could do the job
which is a shift from we believe
we have the votes to joe biden believes
she can do the job if confirmed which is
what we don't know so i know it's a
small shift pat but
that is a shift in language about nira
tandon that's an interesting statement
because i think it goes without saying
right if you didn't think that she could
do the job you wouldn't know
her to begin with but it does sound like
now they're starting to recognize that
they may not have the votes
and how funny is it that republicans are
opposing her because of her mean tweets
i mean really
four years of trump they claim to not
have seen those tweets
right that trump sent out they didn't
see them they didn't have a chance to
catch those tweets
but now all of a sudden they are uh very
much um
you know up to date with what nira
tandon has said they know all of her
tweets over the last eight years
although they didn't hear
kelly lefler didn't hear about grabbing
by the [ __ ] but
uh i'm sure if she were still in the
senate she'd be saying oh those tweets
are very concerning just like
susan collins is saying hey here's a
bitcoin story
last week bitcoin had another major
run-up
and then on monday things cooled off
with bitcoin elon musk saying he thinks
it's too high
but also joe biden's treasury secretary
janet yellen warning
that bitcoin is a quote extremely
inefficient way to conduct monetary
transactions and bitcoin prices tumbled
arguably only partially because of what
janet yellen said
we don't know what the future of bitcoin
is i think at this point pat
whatever near uh i'm sorry not near
attendant whatever janet yellen
and whatever near attendance is but
whatever janet yellen says or whatever
when you start to see hedge funds
companies like tesla and so many others
say hey you know what we're going to put
one percent of our assets in bitcoin as
a hedge we're going to put two
we're going to accept bitcoin as payment
i think the idea
at this point of bitcoin going away is a
fantasy idea now
will it be worth ten thousand a coin or
fifty thousand a coin or a hundred
thousand or a million a coin as some are
saying
i don't pretend to know i have no idea
but at this point i don't think it's
going away
yeah i mean the price goes all over the
place and you could tell me that within
the next week it'll lose half of its
value and i would believe you you can
tell me that within the next week it'll
double its value and i would also
believe you
uh so it's not the safest investment for
sure but you know people like to put a
little bit of money into it now we're
starting to see companies do the same
thing um yeah i think the big risk with
bitcoin is
governments around the world deciding to
try to shut it down and of course
bitcoin proponents will say well it's
decentralized so they couldn't even do
it if they wanted to
um but i wonder if like the u.s
government decided to make this like
full-throated full-fledged uh attack on
bitcoin if they would be able to go
after them successfully because
you know with the possibilities of being
able to commit financial crimes
and you know have these purchases not
being tracked the possibility of not
having to pay taxes on transactions that
sort of thing
maybe the us government would feel that
it's right to uh go after it and maybe
that would take the price we just don't
know
i think that the the path for the u.s
government to attack bitcoin would be
one creating law where gains
on bitcoin are taxed at a separate and
absurdly high rate now of course what
that will cause is people
to simply lie or to try to
just simply not declare their bitcoin
holdings or whatever the case may be
and also going after and trying to
prevent
exchanges from operating in the united
states because
you i really don't see how you shut
bitcoin down it's a protocol
after all but i do see ways that a
determined u.s federal government
could really make it a pain in the ass
to deal with bitcoin i don't know if
they're determined to do it however
yeah i don't know if the biden
administration would want to go after it
especially because i think people are
really coming around to bitcoin now and
you know it's it's becoming more and
more popular adoption is happening
yeah and people want a diverse amount of
currency they want to be able to
like hedge their bets and be able to
invest in the stock market and a little
bit of crypto and
gold and all of these different things
and so yeah it's going to be tough to
reverse course at this point especially
with
bitcoin being what around 50 000 a coin
at this point
um but we'll have to see it is crazy too
how elon musk can just make a statement
and the
price of bitcoin will soar or tank or
janet yelling can come out with a
statement and the same thing will happen
i mean it does seem really
flimsy in that regard it's quite
volatile in that sense
but if anyone who's been in it you know
for any period of time has obviously
made a lot of money even with you know
the dips this week it's still up so much
i've said before on streams on january
1st i sold 15
of my bitcoin to lock in some gains and
it basically doubled since then now i
don't regret it i took gains off the
table
uh went back to us dollars and was able
to put that money away but
i have i don't even i'm not in it
because i pretend to know where it's
going i'm in it because
i'm interested enough to have uh
some portion of my money in more
speculative assets
an amount i can afford to lose certainly
and that's it and otherwise i'm just
waiting it out
seems like there's a lot of bitcoin
pumpers at this point oh yeah people who
want to see it go up to a million
dollars a coin
which it very well could i mean it may
take a few years before something like
that happens
uh but yeah there are really a lot of
people who want to push this thing up
no question no question whatsoever and
we will
we will see what happens in the coming
weeks and march historically a bad month
for bitcoin but you it hasn't been
around that long that we can necessarily
say that
it's a pattern it's just it's happened
to be that way
uh since bitcoin has been around i make
no predictions
i have no expectations uh and i am
curious to follow it and and to see what
happens
we will be back tomorrow with number one
a new show and number two
also a new bonus show i will see you
then
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]